we're asked to graph the circle X plus 5
squared plus y minus 5 squared equals 4
I know what you're thinking what's all
of the silliness on the right hand side
this is actually just the view we use
when we're trying to debug things on
Khan Academy but we can still do the
exercise so it says drag the center
point and perimeter of the circle to
graph the equation so the first thing we
want to think about is well what's the
center of this equation well a standard
form of a circle is x minus the
x-coordinate of the center squared plus
y minus the y-coordinate of the center
squared is equal to the radius squared
so x minus the x-coordinate of the
center so the x-coordinate of the center
must be negative 5 because the way we
can get a positive 5 here's by
subtracting a negative 5 so the
x-coordinate must be negative 5 and the
y-coordinate must be positive 5 because
it's y minus the y-coordinate of the
center so y coordinate is positive 5 and
then the radius squared is going to be
equal to 4 so that means that the radius
is equal to 2 and the way it's drawn
right now I mean we could drag this out
like this but this the way it's drawn
the radius is indeed equal to 2 and so
we're done and I really want to hit the
point home of what I just did so let me
get my little getting my scratch pad out
oh this sorry for knocking the
microphone just now so that equation was
X plus 5 squared plus y minus 5 squared
is equal to 4 squared and so I want to
rewrite this as this is X minus negative
5 X minus negative 5 squared plus y
minus positive 5 positive 5 squared is
equal to and instead of writing it as 4
I'll write it as 2 squared and so this
right over here tells us that the center
of the circle is going to be NAIT x
equals negative 5 y equals 5 and the
radius is going to be equal to 2 and
once again this is no magic here this is
not just you know I don't want to just
memorize
well you'd appreciate that this formula
comes straight out of the Pythagorean
theorem straight out of the distance
formula which comes out of the
Pythagorean theorem
remember if you have some Center in this
case it's the point negative 5 comma 5
so negative 5 comma 5 and you want to
find all of the X's and Y's that are 2
away from it so you want to find all the
X's and Y's that are 2 away from it so
that would be one of them X comma y this
distance is 2 and there's going to be a
bunch of them and when you when you plot
all of them together you're going to get
a circle with radius 2 around that
Center let's think about how we got that
actual formula well the distance between
that coordinate between any of these X's
and Y's it could be an x and y here
could be an x and y here and this is
going to be 2 so we could have our
change in X so we have X minus negative
5 so that's our change in X between any
point X comma Y and negative 5 comma 5
so our change in our change in x squared
plus our change in Y squared so that's
going to be Y minus the y-coordinate
over here squared is going to is going
to be equal to the radius squared so the
change in Y it's going to be from this Y
to that Y if we this is the end point
it'd be the end - the beginning Y - 5 y
minus 5 squared and so this shows for
any X Y that is 2 away from the center
this equation will hold and it becomes
I'll just write this in neutral color x
+ 5 squared plus y minus 5 squared is
equal to the radius squared is equal to
2 or let me just write that is equal to
4 and let me make it I I really want to
you know I I dislike it when formulas
are just memorizing you don't see the
connection to other things notice we can
construct we can construct a nice little
right triangle here so our change in X
is that right over there so that is our
change in X
change in X and our change in Y our
change in Y not the change in Y squared
but our change in Y is that right over
there
change in Y our change in Y you could
view that as Y minus y so this is change
in Y is going to be Y minus 5 and our
change in X is X minus negative 5 X
minus negative 5 so this is just change
in x squared plus change in Y squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared which is
the length of which is this radius so
once again comes straight out of the
Pythagorean theorem hopefully that makes
sense